what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to start up
Black Mirror season six kicking it off
with Joan is awful episode one John
how's it going good I'm ready to feel
terrible and want to take a shower after
ladies and gentlemen you know what I'm
gonna say please go ahead leave a like
that would mean the world also subscribe
click the notification Bell because
we're gonna be covering all the Black
Mirror season six so that way you can
get notified when our next reaction is
up here on this Chanel also want to give
a mention too thank you to everyone who
bought our latest shirt at
shopzeroedition.com we have a Batman
inspired one and one that I have been
wanting to create for such a long time
so we have it right here look at it and
you know what there's even a better
quality image right here on screen for
you all got Michael Keaton Robert
Pattinson bat flecking there because
they're the ones in the DC Universe at
the moment I love it you'll be seeing us
rocket during the flash spoiler talk
live stream and also full interaction
watch along where you sync up with your
own copy of Black Mirror available for
her super sexy rejects over at her
patreon page but with this being the
very first episode that one is made
public for everyone so there's a link in
the description box and pin comment if
you you prefer to sync up with us and
watch the entire experience because
obviously this reaction highlights so
can't feature a good amount of it anywho
guys let's swing into action people
[Music]
it looks like the Netflix look
oh it's her from shit's creek
[Music]
Thomas that's not your neck better tap
in
tap tap tap uh tech company Sandy is
outside waiting for that 10 15.
I know
give me five I need to like
let's hang up
throw on some more tunes
[Music]
oh she's having an affair do it
I'm sorry it's how the board feel I just
put a deposit down on a new apartment
please don't do this
doing her job man I really I am so sorry
about this
I
have this dude arises of Ezra Miller
[Music]
you
the letter you're looking for use chat
gbt to have your affair
no oh no I know it used to be my dream
to run my own coffee shop
that would not have gone out with our
name on it
I'm engaged to Chris yes so good
maybe he's just a little bit like
vanilla
when I was with my ex Mack yeah
um I mean it was just constant
sex and craziness don't confuse toxicity
with passion great and then I met Krish
and he was
sweet and safe and so I just kind of
went with the flow
that's love I feel like I'm not
the main character in my own life story
you're NPC and would you like that to
change
that actually felt like a real therapy
session
thank you
yep embrace your Wild Side this is good
your fiance would love this I love your
hair like that the streaks yeah
he I was uh well Phyllis at the salon
deserves a raise because you look hot as
[__]
in my life you pop back up like a
[__] like an unflushed turd
that's sexy I want to be with you
it's too late man
you can't leave a crash oh my God you've
been at this dinner for what feels like
five minutes cut the tension with a
knife who needs to eat I'm in my usual
sweet and I'll be here for three days
comedian guy from Deadpool 2 Rob Delaney
I want to say I hope you're hungry
amazing
is that salt
and pepper
strain barrier
oh my God it's Netflix yes oh so it's
saying Joan is awful was intentionally
supposed to look like nothing oh my it's
just Netflix
yeah oh my God this is so meta
this is Salma Hayek
she looks like her oh my God uh what oh
my God is this like some algorithm thing
that channels who you really are oh my
God it's a lot like your hair and she's
even called Joan okay what even is the
show this feels like a Scream movie I
would love an algorithm to mirror me
watching a show about a reactor right
now a reaction within a reaction by the
guy who plays crucial
[Music]
no [__] the guy from yesterday and mesh
Patel that's not my hair
[Music]
it's a different ethnicity you know it's
woke Joan is awful the show is woke the
race Bender
oh my God is the message from Matt gonna
be there
boy
it's called Joan is awful it's got Salma
Hayek in it
she looks like John oh my Joan is awful
what the [__]
dreaming they're like all remixes of
Black Mirror episodes
[Music]
I've never responded that way to a
notification from Netflix before
Black Mirror
[Music]
but this is like mirroring today that
crank these shows out fast how did I
this is a prank how did you do this well
I didn't I don't find a [__] bunny I
didn't do anything not so vanilla now is
it spice up the relationship
new episodes every day for the rest of
your life also Sandy is waiting for that
10 15. is he still there he's still
there
oh my God is that really what I sound
like
it must be some like AI generator that
uses them chronologically
how would they really achieve this I
just put pause it down on an apartment
you see what she's like oh my God she is
cold are you not freaked out yeah come
on this is your day too I did not say
that like that that is not what happened
I believe you
Jesus Christ y'all gotta turn this off
man
card okay hey look I was just trying to
make you feel she intentionally tosses
it
oh my God my mom seen it what everybody
can see this
my dad's seen it
why is everyone deciding to watch Joan
as awful Jesus Christ
oh no oh no oh Jesus has Mac been
texting you what
no I hope you deleted those messages I
want to keep watching no no hey Chris I
want it off no how's life at home oh no
he's coming
very vanilla even he's cooking is Bland
no Mac
there was so much crazy wild
oh my God I'm allergic to
uncomfortableness
I haven't gotten over Mike
I crash I think maybe
I don't want some ways this is her more
honest self
yeah without the posturing hey Ben
Barnes
that's what I think
hey no some of the details the whole
thing it's just it's blown out of
proportion I'm packing my eggs
ah
no no
[Music]
psycho just repeats itself oh my God
[Laughter]
oh no that's good that's good that's not
my hair she looks good
show me your phone
what uh it's in the house
it's convenient kill me
goodbye you know all you have to do was
go
I'll go get it and then on your way back
please
nah man you cheated you had it coming
they're right about Ninja
you're awful
the title Joan you just kind of embrace
who you really are
it's going to be on television
everything you do yes
thank you
shame on you
everybody's time it's all anyone can
talk about
how did it come across
technically you're broke your NDA what
what how the board wants you out
now
become the monster everyone thinks you
are
get those ratings
even her therapist is gonna be like I
don't want to work with you anymore
you're terrible
[Music]
this is
sayonara Queen
I have to say that actually legally
the streamberry corporation can do this
what do you agree to when you use
Netflix
yeah what's in the TOs terms and
conditions
I have never seen this before everyone's
going to be checking their Netflix
account yeah
okay well Salma Hayek
yeah pretty cool no well it's not really
Salma Hayek
yes it is
show deploys a digital like this of Miss
Hyatt it's the only way they could do it
she licensed Her Image to them yeah the
entire show is CGI of course there's no
way they could turn around that fast how
do they even know what I'm doing it's
the same it's the same day well you know
when you got your phone face down on the
table and yeah cameras everywhere
microphones it makes me look worse than
I really am so
defamation
yeah page 53 paragraph 12.
creating characters and dialogue for
dramatic purposes
they got you every which way and then
some
my advice is to try and ignore it
[Laughter]
doesn't live Off the Grid or crazy level
of exploitation you could just make this
work in your favor become like an
influencer yeah I'm famous the real life
Joan you could you could totally Market
yourself yeah tell all book everything
turn left in a reality show there's a
way to make it work I'm just saying
there's a way to record
you're the main character now of your
life story congratulations you got what
you wanted
oh
oh boy oh I can't wait for this to be
dramatized
no it's gonna be on TV
this is gonna be on the show
I'm gonna be the guy who can't get it up
for Salma Hayek wanting to not be able
to get it up for
you
I didn't agree to be a public figure
neither did I
except you did but if you have stream
Berry you did too they if they're using
your thing everyone who has stream Berry
agreed to it
would there be some level of outrage
yeah he's doing sucks that she's the
first person they could make her
orangutan if they wanted although I am
guessing the real Miss Blackjack might
I don't know what she's what she's into
you don't know okay Blanchard
idea
gonna do start doing wacky stuff
what
destroy your insides
super embarrassing I guess anyone knows
a reason why these two may not
Merry Christmas
[Music]
do it
Wowie
holy
[__] uh
Salma Hayek wouldn't want to have this
image why don't you just make a public
statement and talk about what the show
is doing because it's already been on
the show I just feel like there's a lot
of different ways I should have gone
about this
Martin
he's turning into Harley Quinn
[Music]
never mind while this nightmares I
thought I'd see myself defecating in a
church yep do they have your face or my
face your face so then Jose is doing the
[__]
what ride do they have to kill my abuela
with these deep fake heretic abomination
specifically covers any Acts or
behaviors Joan May exhibit up to
including and Beyond defecation
laughs
I mean doesn't my Apple have any rights
okay okay
I'm going to start reading the fine
print shove it up your ass and I hope
that you get paper cards in your cameras
and die
yes
[Music]
it's almost a Tim Burton quality about
this episode yeah
oh my God it's like a cinematic
crossover's about to happen
it's like when the xaviors met each
other this is a Multiverse get Kate
Blanchett over here please don't kill me
so much you're lucky I'm a humanitarian
if you don't have any self-respect
that's your thing but to disrespect the
church frankly to disrespect my image
I lose my job they put my entire
existence out there for everyone to
watch and you signed up to be the face
of it you're a [__] enabler I should
be yelling at you I'm
that I shot in a church
they told me to go [__] myself
look I didn't think it was going to be
like my movie Frida but I couldn't
imagine that it was gonna be this
I feel like this is Netflix just like
flexing yeah look what we can get away
with it we could do anything pay for
your password George Clooney is gonna be
in this show no they're sticking his
head on the Thomas the Tank Engine
reboot yes I mean how do you think Kate
Blanchett feels about this
they have taken 100 Years of Cinema and
diminished it to an app
Netflix has never been more narcissistic
the computer thing oh yeah let's
are you a hacker no no no no no I mean I
mean like physically so yeah office
space style her office is all the way at
the top we can't crawl on the side of
the building like Spider-Man
you can just walk in the front door you
can
because you're so [__] Hayek
but isn't all this going to be on the
television yeah
I am some [__] Hayek yes
although Black Mirror is just evolved
into being way more comedic is there a
restaurant I can use of course I'm
afraid that's too public
thanks to your show
all they can think about is coming out
of my bottom
of course
and don't worry I'm just gonna be
she leave the purse there intentionally
it's gonna be able to hack into the
systems
downstairs asking to see you didn't tell
us yourself this morning maybe that's
why
it's got security to Chuck her out
psycho repeats
Battle Rapper this whole floor is
dedicated to content generation r d not
prophetic an infinite content creator
capable of willing entire multiverses
into existence
fully edited programs that would
normally take months to make such as
Joan is awful writers strike schmider's
strike what's so special about her
absolutely nothing
we were looking for a totally average
nobody personally just keep getting her
to launch unique tailored content to
each individual in our database all 800
million of them wow
everyone gets a show about them there's
one for you I couldn't resist yeah
this is actually real and will be
available to stream from Friday why are
they all called is awful yeah does
anybody have other qualities we did try
more affirmative content in the test
cell but we found people like the drama
what we found instead was when we
focused on their more weak or selfish or
Craven moments it confirmed their
innermost fears wants to watch a reality
show with no drama I wonder if this is
based on real Market testing at Netflix
it's an interesting experiment because
it's a combination of a reality show
meets dramatized television it's kind of
interesting
if everyone becomes aware that it's
Michael Sarah hey what's that that's the
variant of Jonah's awful that the Joan
below you sees when she watches the show
what whoa well you're not the original
Joan that's Source Joan
Source Joan the real Joan
look
there Source Stone we inside the show
I'm not the real Joe
played by a digital likeness of Annie
Murphy
who's Annie Murphy
there look familiar shit's creek
oh my God this is an adaptation of
Joan's life you're in a show right now
I'm in a show right now what the hell
who could afford a place like that it's
a TV show House yes I am myself yeah
yeah but it tracks that you believe that
because you're coded to play yourself on
this level
if I'm not here then where am I I don't
know where the real this is not called
Salma Hayek gets everything explained to
her but doesn't understand it
I'm not Eddie Murphy Source Jones
break the machine God you are so boring
I'm gonna kill
here
but you're not really in the yeah you're
gonna kill yourself you billions of
similar
they're not real though would I die
instantly what the [__] is down Ronnie
Murphy no yeah Source Joan already stood
here in reality so okay it doesn't
matter what I want because in the events
that this is based on have already
happened exactly wow
Jones doing it
laughs
computer
[Music]
Jesus
yes wait
get black [__] in there whoa
[Laughter]
[Music]
just taking it slow yeah and trying to
make some
time for myself this commentary of what
real people look like is fascinating
like the main character in my own life
[Music]
yeah I think I do inspiring you know
there's good days
and bad days
to be expected
coffee another shooting this
life
an independent drama you're really there
yeah
[Music]
it's not good oh her dream hi John
hi Abby how you doing
she was able to open up her own coffee
shop yeah all right well that was fun
that was a lot of fun what'd you think
John take it away that was a lot of fun
yeah certainly I mean
God I almost needed a minute to put my
head back together I appreciate it you
know obviously just like the fun wild
Meadow wackiness of it and certainly I
guess this commentary that like you
really
should read the the terms and conditions
uh because I don't know I mean yeah not
that anything like this has happened but
certainly it is one of those things that
comes up frequently in our lives I mean
this this is yeah I mean the amount of
times I hear people commenting on oh I
just mentioned a thing and now it's all
over my algorithms and stuff like that
like yeah as as silly and far-fetched of
a concept as this is in some ways I'm
like well actually would you think about
it it's not that crazy with the Advent
of AI and all these other things
um and yeah I I liked the kind of
mad capness they managed to ring out of
it like it doesn't necessarily feel like
the most heavy thinker of an episode
necessarily but for the kickoff to the
new season I thought it was kind of a
nice place to start and a nice way to
get that foreboding Black Mirror sense
without making me feel like my soul has
just been you know run through some kind
of Filth machine or something like that
uh but what did you think yeah I liked
it overall I I do kind of miss those
days of black I mean not even the last
season really had that like I like the
Striking vipers episode of Anthony
Mackey uh but even that didn't have the
full sense of
the old days of Black Mirror you know
when
it you're left like just miserable it
has escalated a little bit more uh like
it's self-awareness has reached this
whole new level of like comedic effect
yeah it's kind of been that way for a
while yeah and so yeah like and I
enjoyed it though I think I think the
commentary is fun and I like the play on
it is really does feel like a Netflix
Flex like the the metaness of this is
very fascinating to me because
it's it's a commentary on the service
itself that we are all watching this
from and it's warning us of the dangers
of the service but Netflix is so
confident and it's IP and the fact that
we will still consume it and nothing's
going to change that it's saying that we
can even present you with this alternate
reality possible the future that you
might actually one day sort of have
something similar to and we're just
gonna do it while collecting money from
you right yeah exploiting you yeah it's
such a it's such a multi-layer of
exploitation in a way that's like this
should be a cautionary Tale But the
cautionary tale is coming from the
people who stand to benefit from it in
the most sadistic way so it's a really
like weird viewership experience you
know like it feels like I almost feel
like I'm I'm a masochistic viewer in a
way because I'm indulging
and I'm enjoying it and liking what
they're saying but also going
is there anything I should be listed are
they like warning me the their plan of
war attack that they're about to put on
the masses it was all here
it does have that bit of a bit of an
effect though you know yeah so I like
the fun uh unnerving side of it because
it's easy to look at something like this
and go well that's never gonna happen uh
I don't know I wouldn't say never though
maybe not on this like Grand level of a
scale
uh but maybe you know because there is
that thing where uh you know D fakes and
AI technology and they're constantly
trying to use like AI generation you
know like we're at a point in our lives
were
you CGI a person in frame it still looks
cgi'd uh you know so we haven't gone
that far yet uh
but uh in terms of the story itself like
if we were to like there's there's two
sides to talk about this you have the
commentary about we could talk about
what the episode is talking about and
then we could talk about the actual
execution of the episode the actual
execution of the episode was cool to me
where when they do introduce it it's
it's kind of a slow setup but that's to
get you acquainted with her normal
ordinary lifestyle and I did have a
thought when I was
watching
um how how things were progressing and
the way
uh Jones Life Annie Murphy's life not
any Murphy
right yeah yeah she's Joan level one
yeah okay Joan level one sorry confused
on this the way Joan level one's life
was progressing
that it still feels like it's
shot like a cinematic television show
though yeah and then they're doing the
show on stream Berry that is just a
little more dramatized and and
performative yeah you know it's more
acting-y and all that stuff but it still
looks so similar yeah right
so the when the twist came in
of that oh this is level one and we are
still watching a simulation
uh
I appreciated that because I was like
okay well then then that criticism not
even a criticism but just a minor
nitpick that I thought would help
differentiate it a little bit more make
it seem a little more believable like
okay this makes sense more it made more
sense to me now yeah yeah because the
visual aesthetic is very different when
you hop into the real world like okay so
that was all purposeful yeah so that was
a nice choice
um what you think of the comedy though
there were times that comedy was like
real because it became so comedic yeah
yeah it's so like kind of sharply
satirical rather than that like that I I
yeah like Black Mirror up until like
this point has had a sort of pitch black
sense of humor and I I do think it's
maybe telling the Charlie Brooker back
in the day was like I gotta stop this
for a while because like it's getting
too close to real life and I wonder if
in coming back and and you know
reigniting the show again maybe there
was sort of an idea that we'll make this
a little bit lighter and a little more
broad or something like that and it
didn't it didn't bother me like I guess
it does make the show overall feel a bit
lighter so I I guess you know you want
that oomph that impact you know that
that thing that makes your soul feel a
little dirty after a black mirror but at
the same time I don't begrudge at that
it didn't break the illusion it didn't
break the story for me
um and there was a lot that I did find
quite outrageous and and funny
along the way and certainly as the
layers of meta start to crash together
and as uh uh you know level one Jones
starts to take control and and you know
really go for it I I like the that
reveal of of like oh okay if I'm doing
any of this this has already happened
and uh and yeah like you know life is
absurd enough already and I wonder too
if any of this was based on like actual
notes they'd received about stuff over
time or or have been able to like have
access to
um but yeah it is like markedly more
even more comedic to me just like less
Grim I guess is what I would go with in
in terms of an assessment
um and two I mean I thought that like
like any time you make a game out of
celebrities too there's like a lightness
that comes with that and certainly this
has like a huge cast once you get right
down to like every different level and
every different version so like there
was a lot of fun I had with those games
but it does feel markedly like it's not
trying to like warp your soul so much
with what it's doing which uh which you
know I'm curious to see if that flavor
comes back up throughout the rest of the
season maybe this is just a more
palatable one to get us started or
something like that
I don't really care if it's doing that
it was really the the comedy to me
started losing some of its sense of
believability like when it became when
Salma Hayek it was it was when Salma
Hayek entered the picture of Salma Hayek
it started feeling like okay this is not
feeling
it's it's it's it's it's approached a
new level of I'm very much aware now
that I'm watching a television show and
this this constant joke it's starting to
turn like this is the end all of a
sudden and this joke of like constantly
pulling it pulling the joke of
constantly saying yourself like Salma
Hayek Salma Hayek like keep pointing out
it's Salma Hayek it's saying her name
and also with her acting
it was just so if you can't it just
became a very different kind of comedic
sensibility sure at that point where I
was now like now I'm watching a comedy
versus I'm watching something that has
humor in it okay yeah I see what you
mean and maybe that maybe that's the
point I've gotten it there
um I guess it didn't fully jive with me
when it got to that point
uh it's it it started losing some of its
Intrigue I would say yeah I'm actually
I'd be very curious to hear what people
think in general of that because part of
my brain says okay well it has to be
this sort of AI Amalgamated
representation of what we all think of
and perceive Salma Hayek as
um so in in some sense I don't begrudge
at that because it makes sense when the
reveal comes around but in the real time
of the moment of trying to believe that
oh it's the real Salma Hayek coming to
the real Jones house before we know
she's not the real Joan uh yeah I can
absolutely see how that part doesn't
read quite as real and reads like oh
we're having fun with the fact that it's
really Salma Hayek rather than just
trying to portray it naturalistically in
that in that
passage of the story yeah it was so it
was always still enjoyable to me and I
did like the arc that Joan level one had
because
so much of her anxiety comes from a
place of not feeling like she has
control over her life in situations
and then the key to finding her resolve
is to relinquish control and surrender
to it which allows her to get her
Freedom by the end yeah
so I I did uh I did think the The Arc of
that was cool the Michael Sarah Cameo
was fun yeah
um but I also I did like the I did like
the concept though of an out a streaming
service that can duplicate your life in
real time like AI generation is very is
very fast uh you know it's faster than
it's ever been uh with a lot of a lot of
ways of our technology and the response
time on things uh is is incredibly like
impeccable uh and it's so quick and it's
only going to get quicker yeah it's only
it's only going to get quicker and
whether it be text form whether you're
talking about the there's more than like
chat EBT there's like other things out
there that are similar like a Chachi BT
but then you know you got the AI image
generators that people really love
toying around with and then and we are
on the path like people can already do
like those deep fakes impersonationally
those Tom Cruise ones that you see all
the time look amazing
so I I like the commentary on that um
and I I think that
the the concept itself is really cool
because there's ways
because there's many paths they could
have gone down with it of of of like
living in this world of what this AI is
and the commentary on how what we like I
like the CEO line essentially talking
about that would they
people were not responding to the
pleasantries of their life they're
responding to the neurotic sides of Our
Lives because I'm fascinated with real I
am fascinated with reality shows and why
we love reality show so much like it's
really hard to find like a common
like a a real solid thing on like why
reality shows work so well for people
what the what the escapism is for it
there's like something there that people
really do love because it's an Escape
from your own life you're just watching
someone else's life but how real is this
when there's cameras pointed at you and
all these things you know so the concept
of this dramatized thing is in some ways
maybe even closer to reality because
you're not aware at all that there's
cameras like you're not aware there's
surveillance happening yeah and so your
capture something real but then it's
also being enhanced with the writing and
the performances to add a little bit of
extra um to the dramatization of their
lives so in a way you're watching a
blend of a reality show meets a scripted
adaptation of a real life situation that
someone's going through so I think
there's something really cool about it
and I feel like there's I feel like they
could have done a little bit more with
like I don't know I mean I like I like
the route they went I did because
I think there's just so many different
concepts you could have done with this
one concept yeah that there's other
variations would have liked to have seen
but maybe the other variations I would
have liked to have seen maybe not would
have worked for this episode of
you know like there's ways you could
have used it to to your control you know
to like bolster your own Fame become an
influencer
um the way how reality show stars do
that all the time you know where they're
on a reality show they're nobodies and
then like one of those and then they
decide like all right I'm gonna become
an influencer and I'm gonna you know get
brand deals and and use this as a way to
promote myself you know or like oh how
can I control the narrative here yeah
and like what she does do uh so I did
like that but and I but I also love the
idea of like the celebrity getting upset
about the way their likeness is used
because that is also a real problem that
has occurred as well yeah yeah you know
yeah yeah like giving it multiple like
yeah it's it feels like there are a
bunch of levels you could go through but
at least using this scope of yeah like
some kind of piece of media
yeah I mean that's those are two huge
things we're constantly kind of hearing
and talking about as regular people
being preyed upon by fine print and by
you know uh
various kinds of latent surveillance and
then yeah likeness rights and the
ghoulish ways and like like it all kind
of again it is kind of surprising that
Netflix
I don't know it's never really
surprising because obviously they're
just gonna make money off of this and
nothing's really going to change in real
life but it does kind of point to like
the only people really safe from this if
anybody is safe from this is like you
know the owner of the big Corporation
who owns this computer that nobody
understands and I like that they even
addressed it like yeah nobody really
understands how this machine works or
anything it just kind of does its thing
and we all watch
um but yeah like At first I thought it
would just be that one level of like oh
what does the normal person gonna do but
no yeah Salma Hayek is also in theory
stuck in this situation too and is also
being exploited and everyone is being
handed a contract that is way too long
to understand and entrusting that to
somebody else who might not have their
best interests at heart and so yeah
there were a lot of aspects that felt
very relevant wrapped up inside this you
know outlandish packaging uh yeah that
again you know I wonder if there were
harsher versions of this script and you
know things that went in even harder on
you know what it's trying to comment on
that were maybe pulled back yeah because
I like the world that they presented at
the end of what they're they wanted
their end goal to be where everyone
would have that yeah because if everyone
has that then Joe then Joan have nothing
to worry about yeah because then she
everyone would be aware that oh this is
what they do to all of us and then it
could just become fun watching how it
works but then I was like well everyone
get a lot more relaxed about life yeah
and then I was also like but what would
that world entail I like I want to see
that world come to full realization of
what would that world and like this is
one of those Black Mirror episodes where
like it would be cool to see like a
sequel to this but they shut down the
servers
um of what would that world entail if
everyone has their own show so when the
shows is it all like crossovers like
yeah but they're all watching their own
versions become where they're all just
watching versions of their friends and
family yeah totally uh and but if but
like yeah it would be cool to say like
the version where people inhabit it and
embrace it uh instead of just only being
uh rebelling against it and and fighting
against it you know like there's it's a
really it's a really cool scenario
um and so yeah I would have I would have
liked to have seen it because it did
made me Ponder like a bunch of questions
and I do think in our reality like the
world we live in I feel like
yeah I I feel like that um
I feel like a lot of us would like that
I think a lot of us would embrace it
because it would be exploitative of our
uh sure are very
um our narcissistic sides I think it
would be real real telling of that and I
feel like a lot of us would hate it but
I think there'd be a lot of us who would
really like it too at the same time just
to watch how it unfolds and to watch it
play out and stuff and
there would be people who would
absolutely totally be down for it so
yeah so I wanted to see that version as
well like I'm not saying like this this
show goes down the episode goes down for
me because we didn't get that I was like
I'm saying this is why I like the
concept so much yeah yeah because the
the possibilities of where this world
building could have gone with this one
thing
I was like oh it didn't have to end here
it it could have gone more yeah they
talk about multiverses and you really do
feel like yeah you could yeah you can
see how
I don't know you want to see yeah how
the like the furthest extent of this
goes instead of breaking the machine
while it's still kind of just beginning
to start this phenomenon like yeah what
would it like and maybe that's part of
what's kind of different now about the
show is like this does have like a a
nice resolve and a happy ending I guess
I would call that which is not you know
what I usually typically associate black
mirror with and so yeah in some ways I
feel like you could go even further even
more dystopic and yeah there are like
multiple extrapolations on this idea
and so I kind of do hope that maybe as
like this situation in real life expands
they might come back and touch back on
it at some point like I don't know Joan
is the Revenge of Joan is awful or
something like that later down the line
because yeah like there are just so many
implications and we we mostly just watch
as people are dismayed by it but what
about the people who love this and what
about the people who are only going to
become worse and and get higher and
higher off this experience of having
this Spotlight thrust upon them and
whatnot like in reality shows I think
sometimes one of the fun parts of a
reality show is watching The Reunion
because what happens in a reunion is
those people have had months away from
the events that happened and then they
come back and watch the reality show and
see how it's all edited and put together
and see what all their friends or family
said when they weren't around you know
yeah and then in the reunion it's a big
confrontation of those things and I
think that would have been cool to see
how watching everyone else's shows
would intersect is that how you see me
yeah how you appear in somebody else's
life show and it's like if we both have
a stream like if I have a stream Berry
account and John is a stream Berry
account and we're in the same room with
the events of John show play out
different yeah in my show Even though
perspective yeah yeah that's what I mean
I think I think there was a lot of
really cool things they could it's you
don't have time for all that that's like
you would have like a whole season you
have to start the episode out where it's
already established but yeah it's a very
different episode not the introduction
of the first one it is it would have to
be like this is already happening yeah
and you're living they're plopping you
into the a world where this is already
happening
um so yeah it would be cool to see like
a follow-up for it because I do think
there's real complicated things that
could happen that would make for an even
more interesting conversation what they
presented here well yeah and with the
idea just the final just like it was
seeing a version of this too where how
do people behave now that everyone
accepts that their life is on display
versus finding out your life has been
put on display and like I think we can
all kind of relate to how you would
react to that whereas if this is just
the norm I feel like everyone would be a
little bit different yeah you know in
their behavior and the way they
approached all of this yeah
I don't know it's at least I I at least
appreciate that it is rich in ideas and
we can sit here and be like man there
are just so many ways you could take
this in so many like it's a rich idea
and that's cool yeah I appreciate that
episode's quirky actor was still really
good
um I enjoyed everyone's presence quite a
lot
so yeah had a had a fun time with that
one had a fun time Black Mirror still
gets it's still thought provoking
um and at the end of the day that's what
I really wanted was just another
thought-provoking Black Mirror alrighty
guys well what did you think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
uh be sure to subscribe leave a like and
let's end this with a patreon
John real quick off the top of your
ahead who would you want to see a stream
Berry show about make it fast come on
John don't think about it don't think
about how to do that thing John I want
to interrupt me with the names
TV what's her show what's the Rio
Hammond is one of the best people on the
patreon but I know because my closed
doors that there are dark things lurking
within yourself so she appreciates it
that night and I want to see what that
is all about and then what details we're
talking I want a guest star on your show
you know I mean she comes across so kind
and so selfless and so giving but at the
end of the day she comes home looks in
the mirror is like yeah look at you
you're such a good person look at how
how much you do for the past she's a
good person yeah it sounds like a
positive show yeah yeah yeah I just
heard talking herself up the whole time
and none of it's authentic or real oh my
God feed her ego and be loved by
everything really viewer my God I
definitely do this is all true it's not
an algorithm
and uh terrible that's terrible what
you're doing her but I will be her
biggest viewer and I will tune into
every episode and I'll be out there
Maria she's a real one don't trust the
algorithm
I love you Maria don't listen to a word
I said it's all fake it's all fiction
destroy the super computer
stay pledged we love you love you Maria
you know John didn't mean it I didn't
mean it
you're uh awful Human music John is
awful awful
[Music]